alors oui 23 la série de lille at-on
déjà vu aussi si on peut faire un truc
alors ça peut être grossier statut
simple émission peine surprise plein
direct un truc tu sais on s'est
renseigné tout ça concerne la syrie oui
tu va nous suivre
on a prévu un logis avec tout le monde
tulu en tout le monde françois failliot
je suis au courant de rien
l'anniversaire dont tu rêves depuis son
plus jeune âge ça fait un bruit de la
barbe à papa la barbade par ses soins
cyril qu'on a fait à nous n'allons nous
n'avons donc c'est une sale soirée donc
est ce que je dois faire
tu peux tout testé tout est un toit
s'est privatisé mais bon je vais aller
tester autre chose la vérité stade
et vous pensez ça fait une bonne
séquence à jour ces annonces
interviennent tous les mois un barbecue
géant et pour mon anniversaire je
voulais réunir les doux j'aime les
merguez et j'aime l'histoire mon
anniversaire avec tout public on va
parti
tout de suite
en calèche et en bus faire un barbecue
au château de versailles
[Applaudissements]
j'allais personnalisé à chacun je vous
pensais pas qu'on allait vous laisser
comme ça les bras vides avec rien pour
votre anniversaire pas pensé à moi vous
n'avez pas de cadeau pour moi oui
et bien si vous avez une minute nous
avons des cadeaux pour vous mon livre de
chevet c'est le livre de mes meilleures
blagues c'est quoi le livre de mes
meilleures blagues cas vous savez vendre
c'est quoi le livre que j'ai le plus
précieux c'est l'annuaire de toutes mes
ex lot à temps et c'est sincère parce
que je pensais avoir perdu à nrj 12 est
en fait c'est ici que ça se passe et non
c'est ma dignité mais n'était pas loin
mais aussi mon film et faire leur métier
c'est d'ailleurs ce à ce genre de vans a
marché sur une année
c'est que des canaux de merde comme ça
savoir on voit que les gens sachent qu
est ce qui la ramène
mais à votre avis mais c'est quoi une
nappe amène un mouchoir et marc petit
coup de molette si martine fait du
couscous boulette voilà c'est très
marrant c'est pas du tout raciste merci
[Musique]
si vous avez une idée prend le cadeau
des idées pourries enfants alors est-ce
que tu as une bonne idée pour les
aspects g dimanche
le 23 06 un joyau aviv et faire d'eux
des youyous sert il à résister à
d'autres appareils mais le coeur y est
bonne amie la paroisse syrie d'où te
souhaite un joyeux anniversaire
[Musique]
merci à céline